لا يجتمع تخصيب لليورانيوم بنسبه 60%
وحديث عن اغراض سلميه موثوقه هكذا تقول
البعثه الامريكيه لدى المنظمات الدوليه في
فيينا مشككه من جديد في نيات ايران
وبرنامجها النووي فستون في المئه نسبه
بعيده جدا عن
3.6% التي سبق وان نص عليها الاتفاق
النووي المبرم مع ايران عام 2015
وقريبه اكثر من نسبه 90% اللازمه الانتاج
قنبله نوويه
التشكيك الامريكي الذي جاء على وقع
استمرار الاجتماع الدوري لمجلس محافظي
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه تبيعه قلق
اوروبي تمثل في بيان ثلاثي صادر عن كل من
بريطانيا وفرنسا والمانيا اعرب عن القلق
ازاء اعلان ايران تركيب مزيد من اجهزه
الطرد المركزي والشلالات المتقدمه في محطه
فرودول تخصيب النووي الاتحاد الاوروبي عبر
بدوره عن قلقه العميق زام وصفه بالتصعيد
المتسارع والمثير للقلق لبرنامج ايران
النووي وحث طهران على العوده الفوريه الى
التزاماتها واستئناف تنفيذ جميع تدابير
المراقبه والتحقق والتعاون الكامل لتوضيح
انشطتها المتعلقه بتخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه
تزيد على 80% مواقف غربيه سارعت ايرانو
الى رد عليها خشيه ان ينتهي الامر باصدار
قرار يدينها قبيل ختام اجتماعات مجلس
محافظي الوكاله محسن نذير اصل مندوب ايران
لدى الوكاله الدوليه قال ان بلاده تحتفظ
بحق الرد على اي اجراء سلبي يتخذ بحقها
مؤكدا التزامها بمد الوكاله بالمعلومات
التي تحتاج اليها ضمن الاطر الملزمه
قانونيا في اشاره الى اتفاقيه الضمانات
الشامله ومعاهده الحد من الانتشار النووي
الموقعه بين الطرفين والتي تسمح للوكاله
بتفتيش مراكز تخصيب اليورانيوم شرط ان يتم
ذلك وفق اتفاق وتنسيق مسبق على ان اللافت
في هذا السجال الذي يظهر وكان واشنطن كشفت
سرا هو موقف ايراني علني وصريح فقبل ثلاثه
ايام فقط قال رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه محمد اسلامي امام الملا عقب
زياره مدير الوكاله رفيع جروسي لطهران ان
خطوط الانتاج في ايران لا تنتج اليورانيوم
المخصب بنسبه تتجاوز 60% مؤكدا في الوقت
نفسه بان ملف جزيئيات اليورانيوم المخصب
بنسبه
84% قد اغلق